John work with blue line moving joins us
right now John thanks so much for coming
on what what did you see there I'm
embarrassing we have not been there but
what was your impression of what's
happening in East Palestine
uh my impression Tucker thanks for
having me on is that the folks there are
a whole lot more motivated than they
were at this time yesterday and that's a
fact the fact that President Biden has
refused to come to this small town when
he's supposed to be Scranton Joe a Small
Town Hero Of The Working Man and he
can't even show his face in a town of
American citizens that need his
leadership that need the government's
help terribly
and he proved what everybody I think
already knew in this country is that
he's not the leader for this country and
that Donald J Trump is the leader that
we all know he is and he is the leader
of this country and he proved that today
that was leadership
um that I saw today I saw people
standing on the streets screaming for
this man chanting USA USA I mean it just
gives me goosebumps and and to have
President Trump
um personally thank me
um I mean it almost brought me to tears
man to be honest you know I'm just a
humble guy I'm a working man a family
man and uh to be able to you know have
someone like him thank me personally was
a was a was a big deal for me it might I
bet it was so really just kind of big
picture for one for one second since you
were there
2015 Trump emerges out of nowhere then
he becomes the nominee and the media
starts saying wait there are a lot of
Forgotten people in forgotten towns
towns that built this country people who
were born here and have been completely
ignored maybe we should pay some
attention to these people who were dying
younger than the rest of us
I don't think that ever happened did the
people of East Palestine who you spoke
to feel like anyone was paying attention
to them in power
absolutely not I mean these people need
help okay well we're putting illegal
aliens in hotels and five-star
accommodations in New York City and the
people of East Palestine can't even get
a real hotel to stay in for a
significant amount of time or some real
money that they can actually go maybe
and get their own VRBO or something like
that somewhere where they can actually
take a month and get away from the town
and get away from breathing in that
nasty air and having to see hundreds of
workers every river every tributary has
hoses in it and aerators in it and
they're spraying water into these rivers
and who knows where the water is coming
from people don't have any idea what the
hell is going on in their town right now
in East Palestine they have no idea and
that's because of people like Pete
bootage and Joe Biden they literally
have no idea what they're doing and
that's why they're not there because
someone will will call them out and
that's what they're afraid of
yeah
those guys were very lucky that Rural
America is peaceful and law-abiding they
really are unlike a lot of cities that
wouldn't put up with this for one second
John work appreciate it thank you so
much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight